go ask jess what you need to do in order
to get a bigger part in the next song
no ask her what you need to work on
no i want to go talk to her
what i'm not no i'm just one i just want
to talk hi
um i just want you to know like i i
don't know as a mom like i feel like you
know i know dallas didn't get a part in
the first song but she got a bigger part
than kim lee i just kept thinking about
the industry people there that's all and
how i just want her
to do this
[Music]
no i know that you know
okay yeah
tracy's freaking out she's used to
kindly being the star and for me
kinley's a 10 out of 10 but i have six
girls that are 10 out of 10
and tracy needs to get it under control
i'm done with this
what's wrong tracy
i know dallas is a much larger part than
kinley in the second song and i think
that they could have thrown kinley a
little bone kenley says oh oh
she's got a bigger part than kinley in
the second song but i'm not going to
stop
trying my hardest to get henley
everything that she wants out of life
she doesn't want to be a backup dancer
to a bunch of other pop stars in a pop
group she wants to be a superstar
you've got this yeah no i know i'm good
you're kidding me yeah that's not the
end-all like they haven't entered the
world
tracy and i have a good rapport but when
you become a selfish dance mom and
you're only focused on your child then
it's not fair to the rest of the
directive team
can they go out
[Music]
this part's meant to be a party with the
audience to get the audience to do this
with you so if everyone's just doing
this
it looks like a tap dance at a dance
competition but if you're like [ __ ] the
night
hey see the difference a performer
versus
okay here we go let's do that part one
more time
i wanted my kid
to be featured and to be seen you know
in at least one of the songs for the
industry people no and i'm not knocking
you for being that but i do have a
question now if this happens again i
don't want
this to become a thing well that i don't
i'm
no i'm just asking no i'm not pushing
you
it's definitely not going to become a
thing charity just step by eye
okay
i just feel attacked right now i already
i poured my heart out
oh my gosh how did i attack that i need
to step away like i can't even
i honestly feel like trace is a bit of a
narcissist
she thinks everything is about her and
them you've rolled your eyes and said is
it going to be a thing i already told
you multiple times is not going to be a
thing okay
like it's just it's not all about you
[Music]